♪♪
>> Greg: HAPPY TUESDAY,
EVERYBODY.
YEAH.
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
CALM DOWN, EVERYBODY.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ARREST
OF SAM BANKMAN-FRIED, AKA MASHED
POTATO [BLEEP].
IT'S ALREADY STARTING.
HE COULDN'T HIDE FOREVER,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK LIKE A
CROSS BETWEEN MARK CUBAN A CROSS
YOUR HEART BRAH AND A WAD OF
PUBIC HAIR.
IT'S GETTING WORSE.
HE WAS SCOOPED UP IN THE BAHAMAS
ON MONDAY AND IS ACCUSED OF
DEFRAUDING INVESTIGATORS OUT OF
BILLIONS.
CHARGES INCLUDE WIRE FRAUD,
SECURITIES FRAUD, MONEY
LAUNDERING.
FORTUNE CALLED HIM THE NEXT
WARREN BUFFETT.
BUT IN THEIR DEFENSE, IT'S A
COMMON NAME.
THAT JOKE DESERVED A BETTER
LAUGH.
THANK YOU.
IT REALLY IS A GOOD JOKE.
SCREW EVERYBODY.
LET'S RECAP WHAT THIS CLOWN DID.
SINCE LAUNCHING IN MAY 2019 HIS
CRYPTOCURRENCY FIRM FTX RAISED
1.8 BASEBALL AS A SAFE PLATFORM
FOR TRADING ASSETS BUT THAT WAS
AS SAFE AS FINDING A SUITEDABLE
DATING PLATFORM ON A SUBWAY
PLATFORM.
BY THE WAY CRYPTOCURRENCY IS
LATIN FOR NOT REAL MONEY.
THEN DIVERTED THOSE IF YOU
UNDERSTAND TO ANOTHER COMPANY
WITHOUT TELLING ANYONE AND MADE
A BUNCH OF UNDISCLOSED
INVESTMENTS LAUGH ASH REAL
ESTATE PURCHASES HUGE DONATIONS
TO DEMOCRATS MIDTERMS OF COURSE
AND NOT ONCE DID HE CONSIDER
BREAST REDUCTION SURGERY.
HE COULD HAVE USED THE FAT TO
MAKE SOAP AND THEN HE COULD HAVE
USED THE SOAP.
BUT INSTEAD HE'S GOING TO BE THE
MOST POPULAR GUY IN HIS CELL
BLOCK.
HE'S GOING TO GET PASSED AROUND
LIKE ME WHEN I DRESS UP AS A
PLATE OF POTATO SKINS.
AND I DO.
YOU KNOW, I KIND OF WISH I KNEW
HIM IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I WOULD HAVE MADE IT TO SECOND
BASE.
THE WHOLE TIME HE WAS TELLING
INVESTIGATORS, INCLUDING
CELEBRITIES HIP NOTICE TIED BY
HIS CLEAVAGE THAT IT TRULY WAS
THE SAFEST INVESTMENT BUT THEN
IT IMPLODED AND FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY.
AND THE PYRAMID SCHEME WAS
EXPOSED LIKE SAM'S D CUPS IN A
WET T-SHIRT CONTEST.
MEANWHILE ACTUAL PYRAMIDS ARE
LIKE HUMANS, LEAVE US OUT OF
THIS.
AND GO SLAVES!
DON'T KNOCK THE PYRAMIDS.
IF I COULD AFFORD IT, I WOULD DO
THE SAME THING FOR MY GRAVE.
THEY SAY YOU CAN'T TAKE IT WITH
YOU, BUT HOW DOES ANYONE KNOW
THAT?
BUT I FEEL BAD FOR BANKMAN
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT IN COMMON.
FOR ONE, WE BOTH PRETEND TO
DONATE MONEY.
AND WE'RE BOTH POLLY AMOROUS,
ALTHOUGH I SLEEP WITH PEOPLE.
BUT THIS WHOLE THING IS A LESSEN
IN WHY IT'S GOOD TO TRUST YOUR
INSTINCTS WHEN IT SEEMS LIKE
SOMEONE'S MORE FULL OF CRAP THAN
AND A NAVARRO'S BIDET AFTER
CINCO de MAYO.
THAT WAS HARD TO SAY.
YOU APPLAUD OVER THE MEANEST
THINGS.
YOU KNOW SOMEONE IS FULL OF IT
WHEN THEY VIRTUE SIGNAL.
HE SAYS HE'S VEGAN.
SURE HE GOT THAT FAT EATING
VEGETABLES.
NOT POSSIBLE.
BUT THAT'S THE ARMOR THEY DONE
TO AVOID THEIR REAL MOTIVES
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
ANYONE WHO SAW THIS VIDEO AWHILE
BACK KNEW SOMETHING WAS UP.
>> SAM IS NOT THE TRADITIONAL
BILLIONAIRE BECAUSE HE BELIEVES
IN THE CONCEPT OF EARN TO GIVE.
>> EARNING TO GIVE IS THINKING
ABOUT WHICH CAUSES, WHICH
CHARITIES SAVED THE MOST LIVES
PER DOLLAR.
>> NEXT YEAR HE'S PLANNING TO
DONATE $500 MILLION A YEAR.
AND NEXT DECADE, HE WILL
PROBABLY GIVE AWAY MORE THAN
$10 BILLION.
AND HE IS FUNDING EVERYTHING YOU
CAN THINK OF.
GLOBAL WARMING.
>> ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS
WE HAVE TO TACKLE TOGETHER AS A
WORLD.
>> COVID-19 PREPAREDNESS.
>> WE HAVE TO BE READY FOR THE
NEXT PANDEMIC.
>> AND, OF COURSE, ANIMAL
WELFARE.
>> ANIMALS DESERVE TO LIVE JUST
LIKE WE DO.
IT'S ALSO WHY I'M VEGAN.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE LIVE ACTION
ERNIE FROM SESAME STREET.
EVEN A FIFTH GRADER COULD WATCH
THAT AND THINK THERE'S NO WAY
I'M GIVING A DIME TO THIS OLD
CAFETERIA LADY WITH SAGY BOOBS.
BUT, AS RECENTLY AS LAST WEEK
THIS KNUCKLEHEAD WAS STILL
POSTURING.
>> LOOK, I SCREWED UP.
LIKE I WAS CEO, I HAD A
RESPONSIBILITY HERE.
I HAD A RESPONSIBILITY TO BE ON
TOP OF WHAT WAS GOING ON THE
EXCHANGE.
I WISH I HAD DONE MUCH BETTER AT
THAT.
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING, THERE
WERE DOCUMENTS DRAFTED UP AS,
YOU KNOW, BY LEGAL THAT WERE
COVERING WHAT WAS HAPPENING,
AND, YOU KNOW, FRANKLY I HAVE
SORT OF A TENDENCY TO BE
INVOLVED IN MANY THINGS, TO BE,
YOU KNOW, SPREAD THIN SOMETIMES.
>> Greg: SPREAD THIN?
EVERY TIME I SEE HIM I THINK OF
THE SLOW MOTION OPENING OF BAY
WATCH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I STILL DO AS A MATTER
OF FACT.
AND WHAT OF THE SUSPICIOUS
TIMING OF HIS ARREST, HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO TESTIFY BEFORE
CONGRESS THIS WEEK.
THERE HE WOULD HAVE BEEN GRILLED
LIKE A HALF POUND PATTY AT
GEORGE FOREMAN'S HOUSE BUT NOW
HE'S EXEMPT AND HIS
BENEFICIARIES ARE OFF THE HOOK
LIKE THE WHALE TRAPPERS WHO
THREW BACK JOY BAHAR.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WHY?
NO.
THERE'S NO -- DON'T EGG ON MY
WRITERS.
SO ONCE AGAIN, THE PUBLIC GETS
NOTHING.
WAS HE SPARED BECAUSE HE HAS A
HISTORY OF DONATING MILLIONS TO
DEMOCRAT CAMPAIGNS?
WELL, DOES A BEAR CRAP IN THE
WOODS?
OR A HUMAN WHO IDENTIFIES AS A
BEAR.
WE CAN'T SAY FOR SURE BUT AFTER
ALL I WILL I'M A COMMENTATOR NOT
AN ANCHOR I CAN TIE THIS OUGHT
TO CATTLE MUTILATIONS IF I WANT
TO.
TUCKER'S NOT THE ONLY ONE WHO
CARES ABOUT COW CRIME.
BUT MAYBE HE'S BEING SPARED
BECAUSE HE WAS THEIR KIND OF
DEMOCRAT SO THEY LOOK THE OTHER
WAY FASTER THAN HANNITY WHEN I
ASKED HIM TO SHAVE MY BACK.
UNLIKE ELON MUSK WHO THE DEMS
DEEM EVIL, EVEN THOUGH HE'S
TRYING TO HELP SHAREHOLDERS NOT
BILL CAN THEM BUT THAT'S HOW
DEMS TREAT SOMEONE FIGHTING
CHILD PORN.
I GUESS THEIR PREFER THEIR
BILLIONAIRES TO BE PHONEY
LEFTISTS INSTEAD OF REAL PEOPLE
DOING REAL STUFF.
IF ONLY SOMEONE WOULD HAVE
QUESTIONED WHAT THIS FRAUD WAS
UP TO THREE YEARS AGO WHEN HE
STARTED THIS MESS BUT THEY WERE
TOO BUSY TRYING TO GET ANOTHER
BILLIONAIRE WHO WAS DOING REAL
STUFF FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> PERIOD.
>> Greg: TONIGHT'S GUESTS, HIS
ANTI WOKE SCRIP PROMOTE LIBERAL
THREATS AUTHOR OF THE BRAND NEW
BOOK THE NEW PURE TAPE, ANDREW
DOYLE
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: HE'S ONE GIFT WE WOULD
LIKE TO UNWRAP EARLY.
HOST OF CAN'T CANCEL ROB SMITH,
ROB SMITH
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WOW.
DON'T HATE HER BECAUSE SHE'S
BEAUTIFUL, THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHER REASONS
>> Kat: YEAH.
>> Greg: FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
KAT TIMPF!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: AND HIS OPPONENTS END
UP LIKE THE THREE WISE MEN.
SEEING STARS.
MY MASSIVE SIDE KICK AND THE NWA
WORLD CHAMPION TYRUS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SO ANDREW,
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
SUCCESSFUL GREAT NEW BOOK.
IF YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR WITH
ANDREW DOYLE, HE WAS ON THE
FOREFRONT OF SATIREIZING WOKE
CULTURE ONE OF THE EARLY PEOPLE
ON TWITTER I WON'T SAY WHO YOU
DID.
>> WHO I WAS I INVENTED A
CHARACTER NAMED TAKE TANYA MA
GRAPH WHO WAS ONE OF THOSE POSH
YOUNG FEMALE INTERSECTIONAL
ACTIVISTS WHO'S REALLY RICH HAS
EVERYTHING IN THE WORLD BUT
THINKS SHE IS OPPRESSED.
>> Greg: LIKE EVERY WOKE PERSON.
>> Andrew: EXACTLY.
SOMETHING FUNNY ABOUT PEOPLE
COMPLAINING ABOUT BEING
OPPRESSED WHEN THEY GO BACK TO
THEIR MANCHIN.
SHE THINKS SHE'S THE NEW MARTIN
LUTHER KING.
>> Greg: BETTER.
>> Andrew: YEAH, SHE'S BETTER.
>> Greg: SHE KNOWS IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE CHARACTER IT IS ABOUT
THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN.
>> Andrew: AND ALSO HE HAD TOXIC
MASCULINITY.
>> Greg: YEAH, HE WAS A MAN.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS WHOLE
SITUATION?
STRANGE GROUP.
>> Andrew: I'VE BEEN READING THE
BACK STORY.
FIRST OF ALL I DON'T TRUST
ANYONE WHO DOESN'T OWN A HAIR
BRUSH, NO INTEREST IN THAT.
BECAUSE HE HAS A HOB ITY KIND OF
LOOK.
BUT IF YOU LOOK INTO HIS
BACKGROUND, THEY WERE ALL LIVING
TOGETHER, ALL THESE FTX
EXECUTIVES WERE LIVING TOGETHER
IN THIS LUXURY PENTHOUSE IN THE
BAHAMAS BUT ALL HAVING SEX WITH
EACH OTHER.
NO WONDER THEY LOST THE MONEY
THEY WERE DISTRACTED.
THEY SAID THIS IS WE'RE INTO
POLY AMRY WHICH WE CALLED
CHEATING.
WHAT A GREAT NEW BRANDING.
IF YOUR PARTNER CATCHES YOU I'M
NOT CHEATING I'M POLLY AMOROUS.
AND THAT'S WHO I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
AND IF YOU FILE FOR DIVORCE
THAT'S A HATE CRIME.
>> Greg: AND HERE I THOUGHT POLY
AMOROUS MEANT YOU HAD SEX WITH
BIRDS.
>> Tyrus: OH, POLLY WANT A
CRACKER.
GOT IT.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
AND I AM A CRACKER, SO THERE YOU
GO.
>> Tyrus: I KNOW.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I CAN SAY THAT.
ROB, HAPPY HOLIDAYS.
>> Rob: HAPPY HOLIDAYS.
HAPPY HOLIDAYS.
LOOKS LIKE CHRISTMAS EXPLODED
ALL OVER ME.
JUST THE THOUGHT OF THIS GROUP
OF PEOPLE HAVING SEX WITH EACH
OTHER IS LIKE SOMETHING OUT OF
NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC.
WHEN I'M LISTENING TO THE STORY
I'M THINKING ABOUT IT, THE THING
THAT'S MOST OFFENSIVE TO ME IS
JUST THEIR LOOKS FIRST OF ALL.
THIS GUY LOOKS LIKE A CROSS
BETWEEN NORMAN BAITS AND SOMEONE
WHO CAN'T BE WITHIN A HUNDRED
FEET OF A PLAYGROUND WHICH IS
WEIRD.
AND THEN THE GIRLFRIEND, IT'S
LIKE IMAGINE YOU'RE THE ACTRESS
THAT GETS TO BE HER IN THE HULU
LIMITED SERIES.
YOU GO IN THE MIRROR AND YOU'RE
LIKE, OH, IS THIS WHAT I LOOK
LIKE?
THIS CHICK IS AT THE BAR AT
5:00 A.M. AND THE LAST TWO GUYS
DECIDE TO GO HOME WITH EACH
OTHER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I LOVE HOW THERE'S LIKE
BILLIONS BEING SWINDLED BUT WE
ARE NOT GOING TO LET GO OF THEIR
LOOKS.
IT'S LIKE, WE'LL LEAVE THAT FOR,
LET FOX BUSINESS HANDLE THE
MONEY STUFF, WHY ARE THEY SO
WEIRD LOOKING?
I DON'T KNOW
>> Kat: IF ANYTHING IT KIND OF
GIVES HOPE TO REALLY UGLY
PEOPLE.
THAT THEY CAN BE JUST AS
MANIPULATIVE AS THE REST OF US.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
THAT IS TRUE
>> Kat: NEVER LOOKED AT IT THAT
WAY.
>> Greg: YOU DID.
BUT DID YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
INSIGHTS INTO WHAT'S GOING ON --
DID YOU KNOW HE WAS DENIED BAIL
BECAUSE THEY CONSIDER HIM A
FLIGHT RISK.
THAT'S A PIECE OF NEWS.
I DON'T NORMALLY GIVE NEWS.
I'M SO PROUD OF MYSELF
>> Kat: THE LAWYER TRIED TO
ARGUE SAYING HE HAD ADD AND
DEPRESSION AND INSOMNIA FOR THE
PAST TEN YEARS.
AND I'M LIKE, AM I SUPPOSED TO
BE GETTING STUFF FOR THOSE?
BECAUSE I ALWAYS HAVE ANXIETY
AND MY ADD WAS COMBINED TYPE AND
SO NOTICEABLE IT WAS DIAGNOSED
LIKE 30 YEARS AGO AND I'M DOING
FINE.
>> Greg: YOU'RE DOING GREAT
>> Kat: REALLY AM.
>> Greg: GOOD FOR YOU YOUNG LADY
>> Kat: THANK YOU.
>> Greg: SHE THINKS SHE'S ON A
TV SHOW.
WE DO THIS FOR THERAPY.
TYRUS, DO YOU FEEL BAD FOR THE
CELEBRITIES THAT WERE SCAMMED BY
THIS GUY?
OR DO YOU FEEL BAD FOR ANYBODY
IN THIS WHOLE SCENARIO?
>> Tyrus: ANYBODY WHO WAS
SCAMMED BY SUGAR [BLEEP], YEAH,
I WOULD BE A LITTLE UPSET.
BUT IT WAS HIS LOOKS, AND THEIR
LOOKS, THAT MADE THEM BE ABLE TO
PULL OFF WHAT THEY DID.
THEY WERE UNASSUMING,
UNTHREATENING.
THEY WERE THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
WHAT THE PROGRESSIVES HATE THE
MOST, PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE ME.
MEN.
THEY LOOK THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
SO WHEN HE COMES AND SAYS, I'M
GIVING TO CHARITY, EVEN HIS
HORRIBLE STEP BROTHER-ESQUE
VIDEO HE MADE STILL MADE NO
SENSE.
AND HE RAN OUT OF IDEAS BECAUSE
IF YOU'RE SAVING THE PLANET,
THEN THE ANIMALS ARE KIND OF
INCLUDED.
SO HE THEN WENT BACK TO THAT.
AND WHEN HE OPENED HIS FRIDGE,
EVERYTHING IN HIS FRIDGE -- I
DON'T THINK KETCHUP AND MUSTARD
AND RELISH ARE BIG ON THE VEGAN
LIST BUT IT IS BIG WHEN YOU EAT
A LOT OF HOT DOGS AND HE LOOKS
LIKE HE EATS A LOT OF HOT DOGS.
>> Andrew: IS HE SERIOUS ABOUT
THE MONEY?
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG WASN'T
HE THE SECOND BIGGEST DONOR TO
DEMOCRATS ON THE ELECTION CYCLE?
WHICH GIVES THE IMPRESSION
DEMOCRATS AREN'T THE BEST AT
HANDLING OTHER PEOPLE'S MONEY.
>> Tyrus: HE MIGHT GET EPSTEINED
OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
BAHAMAS.
>> Andrew: HE ALSO CLAIMS HE
GAVE MONEY TO THE REPUBLICANS,
SAID IT WAS DARK MONEY.
HE KEPT IT IN SECRET.
HE'S MORE EMBARRASSED ABOUT
GIVING MONEY TO THE REPUBLICANS
THAN MONEY LAUNDERING AND FRAUD.
>> Greg: EXCELLENT POINT.
>> Tyrus: HE'S GOING TO